[Music]
money glamour
fame and fraud this is the story of how
africa's richest woman went from being
worth
3.5 billion dollars to nothing
if you had asked me in 2013 when we
first published that she was
you know worth three billion dollars and
would you know would she be
off the list within a decade i don't
think i would have guessed that
this this definitely was kind of a
textbook case of how to loot a country
so angola was a longtime
portuguese colony and then it went into
civil war for 27 years
after it gained its independence and the
civil war ended
in 2002 and so it was kind of you know
this very
uh a country full of strife
with a and also a very oil-rich country
so there was money flowing in from all
the oil exports
you know some of the money made its way
into the pockets of
of people high up in in the government
her father was the president of angola
for almost 40 years
and so and you know his word was his
word was law essentially right
you know but there was a new mobile
phone company starting in
2000 and lo and behold isabel de santos
has 25
a stake in this new mobile phone network
right while he ran the poverty-stricken
but oil-rich country
isabel garnered significant stakes in
angola strategic industries
banking cement diamonds and telecom
making her the most
influential business person in her
homeland she first came onto the scene
when forbes started doing this list of
africa's richest people in 2011.
and i connected with a very
brave investigative journalist in angola
raphael marquez
who working with with be at forbes
we were able to publish in 2013 a whole
expose of how
she got to be so wealthy and raphael had
gotten
the documentation showing that she got
this stake in the mobile phone company
that she had the stake in the diamond
company that she had
you know the cement that the that you
know how she got these stakes and all
these
so we published this in 2013 and we
forbes said like this this is the
richest woman in africa
when forbes outed her as a billionaire
that year the government spread the news
as a matter of national pride
living proof that the country had
arrived isabel was not shy about her
wealth
she went to events with international
celebrities she's reported to have a
home on a private island in dubai
another residence in london and a 35
million yacht
interestingly when we first before we
publish the investigation
we just said like in january of 2013
when we said oh she's a billionaire
the there was like a congratulatory like
yes this is great news the government of
angola was like this is great isabel de
santos
is a successful businessman she's a
billionaire right wrong
shortly after being pronounced a
billionaire forbes reported on just how
isabel acquired her assets
you know eight months later saying well
actually here's how the billions were
accumulated essentially illegally
kleptocrat style she denied of course
that that had happened she said she was
an independent businesswoman and all
this stuff had come from her hard work
she had stolen state assets for personal
gain
things took a turn when her father
retired as president of angola in 2017.
they issued corruption charges against
her her husband and one of her
associates
they claimed money laundering and
embezzlement
and said that she and her husband and
associate had caused angola to lose more
than 1.1 billion dollars
she denied the charges at the time um
and sadly
her husband sandica docolo died in
in october 2020. isabel is facing
litigation
across the world she is wanted on
embezzlement and money laundering in her
home country
she is being sued by the phone company
in angola where she held shares
portuguese courts froze her telecom
investment assets
forbes has taken her off the
billionaires list her assets have been
frozen by courts in
multiple countries she's being sued um
in a couple other different countries
and
um she's on the hook for hundreds of
millions of dollars
if for some reason she wins the court
case
in any of these places and she gets the
assets back
of course we'll reconsider but we'll see
we'll
cross that bridge when we come to it